the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today involves the
backbone of calculus namely the concept
of limit and perhaps no place in the
history of mathematics is there a more
subtle topic than this particular one
I'm reminded of the anecdote of the
professor who was staring quite intently
philosophically in his home and his wife
asked what are you contemplating and he
said it's amazing how electricity works
and the wife said well what's so amazing
about that all you have to do is flick
the switch and this somehow or other is
exactly the predicament that the limit
concept falls into from the point of
view of computation it seems that what
comes naturally 99% of the time gives us
the right answer but that unfortunately
the 1% of the time turns up almost all
the time in differential calculus for
this reason what we will do is introduce
the concept of limit through the eyes of
differential calculus and we shall call
our lecture today derivatives and limits
and what we shall do is go back to our
old friend who makes an appearance and
almost all of our lectures so far the
case of the freely falling object a ball
is dropped it falls freely in a vacuum
and the distance s that it falls in feet
at the end of T seconds is given by s
equals 16 T squared the question that we
would like to raise is how fast is the
ball falling when T equals 1 in other
words notice that the ball is covering a
different distance here as it falls what
we want to know is at the instant that
the time is 1 and by the way don't
confuse the speed with the displacement
we know that when the time is 1 the
object has fallen a distance of 16 feet
when the time is 1 the object has fallen
16 feet what we want to know is how fast
is it falling at that particular point
now keep in mind that mathematics being
a logical subject proceeds from the idea
of trying to study the unfamiliar in
terms of the familiar what we are
familiar with is the concept known as
average rate of speed
so what we will do is duck the main
question temporarily and proceed to a
different question what we shall ask is
what is the average speed of the ball
during the time interval from T equals 1
to T equals 2 and we all know how to
solve this problem from our precalculus
courses
namely we compute where the ball is when
T is 2 we compute where the ball was
when T is 1 the difference between these
two distances is the distance that the
ball has fallen during this time
interval and we then divide by the time
interval and the distance divided by the
time is precisely the definition of
average rate of speed in other words
during the time interval from T equals 1
to T equals 2 the ball falls at an
average speed of 48 feet per second
again in terms of our diagram you see at
T equals 1 the object is over here at T
equals 2 the object is over here it's
fallen 64 feet and so we compute the
average speed by taking the total
distance and dividing by the time that
it took now again what we have done is
found the right answer but to the wrong
question the question was not what was
the average rate of speed from Teague
was 1 to T equals 2 it was what is the
speed at the instant t equals 1 and we
sense that between T equals 1 and T
equals 2 an awful lot can happen and
that therefore our average speed need
not be a good approximation for the
instantaneous speed what we do next you
see is we say okay let's do something a
little bit differently let's now compute
the average speed but not from T equals
1 to T equals 2 but rather from T equals
1 to T equals 1.1 and computationally we
mimic the same procedure as before we
compute s when T is 1 point 1 we compute
s when T is 1 by the way the only
difference is that it's a little bit
tougher to Square 1 point 1 and multiply
that by 16 than it was the square 2 and
multiply that by 6
Dean the arithmetic gets slightly messy
or if you want to call it that but the
concept stays the same we find the total
distance traveled during the time
interval we divide by the length of the
time interval and that quotient by
definition is the average rate of speed
again in terms of our diagram at t
equals 1 the object has fallen 16 feet
I'll distort this so that we can see
what's happening here at T equals 1.1
the object has fallen 19 point 3 6 feet
and now we compute the average speed
from here to here in the usual
highschool way now again the same
question arises as before namely this is
still an average speed we wanted an
instantaneous speed and our comeback is
to say look at we at least suspect
intuitively that between 1 and 1.1 we
will hopefully get a better idea as to
what's happening at exactly one than we
did on the bigger interval from 1 to 2
in other words where as we don't believe
that 33.6
is the answer to our original question
we do believe that 33.6 is probably a
better approximation to the answer to
our original question than the answer 48
feet per second that was obtained over
the larger interval what the
mathematician does next is he says well
let's stop playing games let's not go
between 1 & 1 point 1 or 1 and 1.0 1
why don't we go between 1 and 1 plus h
where h is any nonzero amount in other
words let's find the average speed from
T equals 1 to T equals 1 plus h and then
what we'll do is we will investigate to
see what happens when H gets very very
small well again we mimic exactly our
procedures before we feed in T equals 1
plus h and compute s which of course is
16 times 1 plus h squared then we
subtract off the distance that the
particle had fallen when T is 1 that's
16 feet we divide by the length of the
time interval
well between 1 & 1 plus h the time
interval is H we
simplify algebraically and we wind up
with this particular expression 32 H +
16 H squared over H and now we come to
the crux of what limits and derivatives
and instantaneous rate of speeds are all
about if you recall it's quite tempting
to look at this thing and say aha I'll
cancel an H from both the numerator and
the denominator and that will leave me
32 plus 16h and notice though the very
important thing that as we mentioned in
previous lectures since you cannot
divide by zero since you cannot divide
by zero it is crucial at this stage that
we emphasize that H is not equal to zero
now of course this is not a difficult
rationalization to make namely in terms
of our physical situation we wouldn't
want to compute an average rate of speed
over a time interval during which no
time transpired and if we let H be zero
obviously from 1 to 1 + H no time
transpires
but the key statement is and we'll come
back to exploit this not only for this
lecture but for the next 1/2 is to
exploit the idea that in our entire
discussion it was crucial that H not be
allowed to equal zero in other words the
average speed between 1 and 1 + H is 32
plus 16h now again without trying to be
rigorous observe that our senses tell us
that as H gets as close to zero as we
want without ever being allowed to get
there 16 H gets as close to zero as we
want also and hence 32 plus 16h
apparently gets as close to 32 as we
wish in other words
it appears that the speed is 32 feet per
second when T equals one and to reuse
the vernacular what we're saying is we
compute the average rate of speed CS of
1 plus h minus s of 1 over H and see
what happens to that as H approaches
zero and in our particular case notice
that this simply means what we came down
to 32 plus 16h over here and then as H
got arbitrarily small
we became suspicious and believed that
as H became arbitrarily small 32 plus
16h became 32 and I'm saying that in
great detail because this is not quite
nearly as harmless as it may seem there
is a great deal of difficulty involved
in just saying as H gets close to zero
32 plus 16h gets close to 32 well
there's no difficulty in saying it
there's difficulty that comes up in
trying to show what this means precisely
as we shall see in just a little while
by the way it's rather easy to
generalize this result namely you may
have noticed in our presentation there
was nothing sacred about asking what was
the speed when T equals 1 one could just
as easily have chosen any other time T
say T sub 1 and ask what was the speed
between T 1 and T 1 plus h we could have
done exactly the same computation in
fact notice down here when we do this
computation the answer 32 T 1 plus 16h
becomes precisely 32 plus 16h when T 1
happens to be 1 in other words this
result here is the generalization of our
previous result that had us work with
the limit of 32 plus 16h at any rate by
this approach it becomes clear then if
the equation of motion the distance
versus the time is given by s equals 16
T squared then at time T equals T 1 the
instantaneous speed appears to be 32
times T 1 and in fact sin
tea one happens to be any arbitrary time
that we choose it is customary to drop
the subscript and simply say what at any
time T are freely falling body in this
case will have a speed given by 32 T and
many of us will remember as this is a
revisited course that this is precisely
the recipe that turns out when one talks
about bringing down the exponent and
replacing it by one less 16 times 2 is
32 and T to a power 1 less than 2 is
just T to the first power or T but
notice now no recipes involved here just
a question of intuitively defining
instantaneous speed in terms of being a
limit of average speeds now in order
that we don't become hypocrites in what
we're doing
recall also that we have spent an entire
lecture talking about the value of
analytic geometry in the study of
calculus the idea that a picture is
worth a thousand words so what we would
like to do now is to revisit our
previous discussion in terms of a graph
you see suppose we have a curve y equals
f of X and I've drawn the curve over on
the side over here we'll make more
reference to it later as we go along but
what does it mean if I now mechanically
compute f of x1 plus Delta X minus f of
x1 over Delta X and by the way again
notice just a question of symbolism
Delta X happens to be the conventional
symbol that one uses in the Analects
geometry approach where we were using H
before but this is simply a question of
notation well the idea is this observe
that if we go to the graph f of f of x1
plus Delta X is this particular height
on the other hand this height is f of x1
consequently our numerator
our numerator is just this distance here
and our denominator which is Delta X
it's just this distance here and
therefore what we have done in our
quotient is we have found the slope of
the straight line that joins P to Q and
here then is why the question of
straight-line becomes so important in
the study of differential calculus that
what is average speed in terms of
analysis becomes the slope of a straight
line in terms of geometry and the idea
you see is that this gives me the
average speed between of the straight
line that joins the average rise of the
straight line that joins P to Q and by
the way this is quite deceptive as any
averages you notice that the man who sat
with his feet in the oven an ice pack on
his head and when somebody said how do
you feel is that on the average pretty
good you see the same thing is happening
over here notice if I had taken a
completely different curve a curve which
looked nothing at all like my original
curve only that also passed through the
points P and Q notice that even though
these two curves are quite different
the average rise from P to Q is the same
for both curves in other words when one
deals with the average one is not too
concerned with how one got from the
first point to the second you see this
is the problem with average rate of
speed in fact the bigger attainment of
oh we work over the more danger there is
that the average rate of speed will not
coincide intuitively with what we would
like to believe that the instantaneous
rate of speed is and you see that's
exactly what this idea here means what
we do to define the derivative the
instantaneous rise at x equals x1 is we
take this quotient and investigate what
happens to it as Delta X is allowed to
get arbitrarily close to zero but let's
emphasize this again Delta X is not
allowed to equal zero you see it's over
a smaller and smaller interval and you
see what's happening here geometrically
to let Delta X get smaller and smaller
means that for a given x1 you are
holding P fixed and allowing Q to move
in closer and closer to P
and what we are saying is is that when
q' assumes this position let's call it Q
sub 1 the slope of the line that joins P
to Q 1 looks a lot more like the slope
of the line that will be tangent to the
curve at the point P and for this reason
what is instantaneous rate of speed when
we're talking about functions become
slopes of curves at a given point when
we are talking about curves you see that
the tangent line to a curve is viewed as
being the limiting position of a court
drawn from a point P to a point Q now at
any rate this will be emphasized in the
text it will be emphasized in our
exercises the major issue now is what
did we really do when it came time to
compute this little gadget in other
words when we talked about the limit of
f of X as X approached a how did we
compute this the danger is and this is
why I've underlined a question mark here
the intuitive approach is to say
something like let's just reflect
replace X by a in here in other words
let the limit of f of X as X approaches
a be f of a in fact this is what we did
without 32 plus 16h in a way what we did
was with 32 plus 16h remember what we
did we said let let's let H get
arbitrarily close to zero and in our
minds we let H equal 0 16 H was then
zero and then 32 plus 16h was then 32
but what we are done is somehow or other
if our intuition is correct
we had arrived at the correct answer but
for wrong reasons because you see in
this expression it is mandatory as we've
outlined this is that X never be allowed
to equal a well you say who cares
whether you allow or you don't aren't we
going to get the same answer and just to
give you a quickie one that we talked
about in our introductory lecture
consider the function f of X to be x
squared minus 9 over X minus 3 and let's
evaluate what this limit is as X
approaches 3
if we were to blindly assume that all we
have to do is replace X by a that would
mean what here replace X by 3 notice
that what we got is what 3 squared which
is 9 minus 9 which is 0 over 3 minus 3
which is also 0 in other words if in the
expression x squared minus 9 over X
minus 3 you replace X by 3 you do get 0
over 0 unfortunately or perhaps
fortunately somehow or other this
definition is supposed to incorporate
the fact that you never allow X to equal
3 see the way we got 0 over 0 was we
violated what the intuitive meaning of
limit was we wound up with the 0 over 0
mess by allowing X to equal the 1 value
it is not allowed to equal here to see
what happened more anatomically in this
particular problem let's go back to our
old friend of cancellation again we
observe that x squared minus 9 can be
written as X plus 3 times X minus 3 and
then we divide by X minus 3 and here's
where the main problem seems to come up
one automatically somehow or other gets
into the habit of cancelling these
things out but the point is since we
have already agreed that you cannot
divide by 0 the idea then becomes that
the only time this is permissible is
when X is unequal to 3 in fact to have
been more precise
what we should have said was not that x
squared minus 9 over X minus 3 equals x
plus 3 but rather x squared minus 9 over
X minus 3 equals x plus 3 unless x
equals 3 and by the way I should add
here what that if x equals 3 then x
squared minus 9 over X minus 3 is
undefined
you see that's what we call 0 over 0
undefined indeterminate t but here's
what bails us out as soon as we say the
limit as X approaches 3 what are we
assuming we're assuming that X can be
any value at all except 3 and the
interesting point now becomes that as
long as X is anything but 3 the only
time you could tell these two
expressions apart was when X happened to
equal 3 so if you now say we won't allow
X to equal 3 then it is true that
whereas the bracketed expression by
itself is not equal to the parenthetical
expression by itself the limit as X
approaches 3 of these two expressions
are equal and in fact one becomes
tempted to say what this case oh here
it's quite easy to see that as X
approaches 3 X plus 3 is equal to 6 and
let me put a question mark here also
because it certainly is true that if you
replace X by 3 this will be 6 but this
says don't replace X by 3 now before
when we replaced X by 3 we go into
trouble so we said we can't do that now
we replace X by 3 we get an answer that
we like and that is the danger that
we'll say ok we won't allow this to be
done unless we like the result and of
course this gives you a highly
subjective subject matter here you see
the point is that somehow or other we
must come up with a more objective
criteria for distinguishing what limits
are and by
the way for the Pollyanna who has the
intuitive feeling for saying things like
well look at this may give you trouble
if you wind up with zero over zero but
what is the likelihood that given f of X
at random and a at random that the limit
of f of X as X approaches a is going to
be zero over zero if you careless and
the answer is that the probability is
quite small except in calculus in which
case every time you take a derivative
every time you are going to wind up with
zero over zero this is why we said
earlier that differential calculus has
been referred to as the study of 0 over
0 you see the whole point is let's go
back now to our basic definition of
average rate of change of F f of x1 plus
Delta X minus f of x1 over Delta X and I
guess when you're writing in black you
have to use white for emphasis so we'll
use this notice that every time you let
Delta X equal 0 you are going to wind up
with what f of X 1 minus f of X 1 which
is 0 over Delta X which is 0 in other
words you are going to get 0 over 0 if
you believe that all this means is to
replace Delta X by 0 you see and the
point is this is not the definition of
this and this is why you don't wind up
with this particular thing well I've
spent enough time I think trying to give
a picture as to what limits mean
intuitively now what I'd like to do is
to devote the remainder of this lecture
plus our next one to investigating more
stringently what limit means in a way
that is unambiguous and you know it's
like everything else in this world when
you want to get something that is
ironclad you you don't get something for
nothing to get an ironclad expression
that doesn't lend itself to
misinterpretation usually involves a
rigorous enough language that scares off
the uninitiated sort of like a legal
document the chances are if you're not a
trained lawyer and the document is
simple enough for you
to understand it must have thousands of
loopholes in it but that same rigorous
language that makes it almost impossible
for the layman to understand what's
happening is precisely the language that
the lawyer needs to make the document
well-defined to him hopefully well with
that as a background let's now try to
give a more rigorous definition of limit
and let's try to do it in such a way
that not only will the definition be
rigorous but it will agree to the best
of our ability with what we intuitively
believe a limit should mean now what I
want to do here is scare you a little
bit the reason I want to scare you a
little bit is I want to show you once
and for all how in many cases what
appears to be honest mathematical
notation is simply a rigorous way of
saying something which was quite
intuitive pictorially to do the
mathematical definition of limit is the
following the limit of f of X as X
approaches a equals L means and get this
given epsilon greater than 0 we can find
Delta greater than 0 such that when the
absolute value of X minus a is less than
Delta but greater than 0 then the
absolute value of f of X minus L is less
than Epsilon
now doesn't that kind of turn you on see
this is the whole problem I will now cut
you in sort of on the trade secret that
makes this thing very very readable
first of all to say that you want to get
arbitrarily close in value you know you
want f of X to be arbitrarily close to L
another way of saying that is what you
specify any tolerance limit whatsoever
which we call Epsilon and I can make f
of X get 2 with an epsilon of L just by
choosing X sufficiently close to a and
by the way again in terms of geometry
that's all the absolute value of a
difference means the absolute value of X
minus a simply means what the distance
between X and a all this says is what I
can make f of X fall within epsilon of L
by finding a delta such that X is within
Delta of a and
by the way this little tidbit over here
is simply a fancy way of saying that
you're not letting X equal a you see the
only way the absolute value of a number
can be zero is if the number itself is
zero the only way this could be 0 is if
x equals a so by saying this little
tidbit over here that this is greater
than zero
that's our fancy way of saying that we
are not going to allow X to equal a now
again whereas this may sound a little
bit simpler than the original definition
let's see how much easier the picture
makes it let's go to a graph of y equals
f of X and in my diagram here here is a
and here is L and what I'm saying is I
intuitively suspect let me write down
what I suspect I suspect that the limit
of f of X as X approaches a is L in this
case namely I suspect that as X gets
closer and closer to a no matter which
side you come in on see that's why we
use absolute value it makes no
difference what is positive or negative
as X gets in tighter and tighter on a I
suspect that I can make f of X come
arbitrarily equal to L in other words if
X is close enough to a f of X it seems
will be close to L and by the way to
complete this problem geometrically pick
your epsilon let's say that epsilon is
this wide then since epsilon is positive
this will be called L plus Epsilon this
will be called L minus Epsilon now what
we do is is we come over to the curve
here all right hopefully these will look
like horizontal lines to you when I get
down to here I then project down
vertical lines to meet the x axis and
now all I'm saying and I think this is
fairly intuitively clear is what that if
X is this close to a f of X will be
within these tolerance limits of L in
other words for any value of x in here C
for this neighborhood of a every input
has its output come with an Epsilon
I fell by the way just one brief note
here something that we'll have to come
back to in more detail in fact I'll do
that in our next example notice here how
important it was how important it was
that I curve was single not single
valued but one-to-one in other words
suppose our curve had doubled back say
something like this notice then when you
try to project over to the curve from L
plus epsilon you don't know whether to
stop at this point or at this point you
see in other words notice that there is
another point down here which has the
same L plus epsilon value in other words
whenever our function is not one-to-one
there is going to be a problem when we
work analytically of being able to solve
algebraic equations and trying to
distinguish this point of intersection
from this point you see if we make a
mistake and bypass this point and came
all the way over to here and thought
that this was our tolerance limit we
would be in a great deal of difficulty
because you see for example for this
value of x its f of X value projects up
here which is outside of the tolerance
limits that are given you see many
things which are self evident from a
picture are not nearly so self-evident
analytically to which we then raise the
question why use analysis at all let's
just use pictures and again the answer
is in this case we can get away with it
but in more complicated situations where
either we can throw out a diagram
because it's too complicated or because
we have several variables and we get
into a dimension problem the point is
that sometimes we have no recourse other
than the analysis let me give you an
exercise that we'll do in terms of
putting the geometry and the analysis
side-by-side let's look at the
expression the limit of x squared minus
two X as X approaches three now of
course we don't want X to equal three
here but let's cheat again and see what
this thing means our intuition tells us
that when X is three x squared is nine
2x is 6 so 9 minus 6 is 3 and we would
suspect that the limit here should be 3
now to see what this means
let's draw a little diagram the graph y
equals x squared minus 2x crosses the
x-axis at 0 & 2 it has its low point at
the point 1 comma minus 1 we don't
sketch these curves it's a parabola and
now what we're saying is is it true that
when X gets very close to 3 is I'm sorry
is it true that when X gets very close
to 3 but f of X gets very close to 3 and
the answer is from the diagram it
appears very obvious that this is the
case fact is that example of non single
value again if you call this thing L and
you now pick tolerance limits which
we'll call L plus epsilon and L minus
Epsilon and now you want to see what
interval you need on the x-axis notice
that in this particular diagram you will
get two intervals one of which surrounds
the value x equals minus 1 and the other
of which surrounds the x value x equals
3 in other words both when X is minus 1
and X is 3 x squared minus two X will
equal 3 see at any rate leaving the
diagram as an aid let's see what our
epsilon-delta definition says and how we
handle this stuff algebraically and how
we correlate the algebra with the
geometry given epsilon greater than zero
what must I do I must find a delta
greater than 0 such that one and I'm
going to read this colloquially I'll
write it formally but really
colloquially such that whenever X is
within Delta of 3 but not equal to 3
then x squared minus 2x will be within
epsilon of 3 now here's the whole point
we know algebraically how to handle
absolute values namely the absolute
value of x squared minus 2x
- three being less than epsilon is the
same as saying that x squared minus two
X minus three itself must be between
epsilon and minus Epsilon
now again we rewrite things in fancy
ways if we wish there are other ways of
doing this I call this completing the
square
well people for 2,000 years have call
this completing the square
namely I rewrite minus three as one
minus four so that x squared minus two x
plus one can be factored as X minus one
squared I'm now down to this form here
then I add four to all sides of my
inequality and have that X minus 1
squared is between four plus epsilon and
four minus Epsilon some fairly
elementary algebra of inequalities here
now here's the key point
remember in my diagram I said to you how
do we know whether we're near three or
near minus one how do we distinguish
when we draw the lines to the curve what
neighborhood we want and notice that all
we're saying is that if X is near three
that means what X is close to three if X
is reasonably close to three then X
minus one is going to be reasonably
close to two and hence be positive point
is that as long as you're dealing with
positive numbers over here see if
epsilon is sufficiently small these will
then all be positive numbers for
positive numbers if the squares obey a
certain inequality the square roots will
obey the same inequality as we have
emphasized in one of our exercises in
other words from here we can now say
this and from this we can now conclude
that if you want x squared minus 2x to
be with an epsilon of three X itself is
going to have to be between one plus the
square root of four plus Epsilon and one
plus the square root of four minus
Epsilon and by the way this is quite
rigorous but I don't think it turns you
on I don't think there's any picture
that you associate with this and so what
I thought I'd like to do for our next
little thing is to come back to our
diagram here and show you what this
really means namely
notice that if epsilon is a small
positive number let's take a look at
this again if epsilon is a small
positive number this is slightly less
than four therefore the square root is
slightly less than two therefore this
number will be slightly less than three
on the other hand four plus Epsilon is
slightly more than four so it's square
root will be slightly more than two and
therefore one plus that square root will
be slightly more than three and what
these two numbers as abstract as they
look like correspond to is nothing more
than this coming back to our diagram and
choosing an epsilon and coming over to
the curve like this and projecting down
like this all we're saying is see what
are we saying pictorially that for f of
X to be within epsilon of L X itself has
to be in this range here and all this
says is that if this very simple point
to compute this very simple point to
compute just by projecting down like
this its rigorous name would be 1 plus
the square root of 4 minus Epsilon
that's this number over here and the
furthest point namely this point here
which again in terms of the picture is
very easy to find that point corresponds
to 1 plus the square root of 4 plus
Epsilon and again notice in terms of the
algebra I need no recourse to a picture
but in terms of the picture
I get a heck of a good feeling as to
what these abstract symbols are telling
me well let's continue on with the
solution of this exercise you see we
didn't want to find where X was we want
to see where X minus 3 had to be in
other words we're trying to find the
Delta we know that X minus 3 is between
these two extremes here consequently and
here's the place we have to be a little
bit careful here this of course is a
positive number because this is more
than 2 this on the other hand is a
negative number because you see 4 minus
epsilon is less than 4 so it's square
root is less than 2
you see so if I subtract two from it
it's a negative number and since Delta
has to be positive if this thing is
negative two minus the square root of
four minus epsilon will be positive so
what I do is to solve this problem is I
simply choose Delta to be the minimum of
these two numbers and then by definition
what do I have that when the absolute
value of X minus three is less than
Delta and at the same time
this is crutial greater than zero in
other words we never let X equal three
for this choice of Delta by how we work
backwards this will come out to be less
than Epsilon and that is exactly what
you mean by our formal definition of
saying that the limit of x squared minus
two X as X approaches 3 in this case
equals 3 for someone who wants more
concrete evidence I think all one has to
do is for example take a number like 1
plus the square root of 4 plus epsilon
that is the widest point on our interval
and actually plug that in for X and go
through this computation of squaring 1
plus the square root of 4 plus Epsilon
subtract twice once plus the square root
of 4 plus Epsilon
carry out that computation and you get
what 3 plus Epsilon that using the upper
extreme you wind up with what in excess
of 3 by Epsilon which by the way is
exactly what's supposed to happen
in fact I hope this doesn't give you an
eyesore I will pull down the top board
again to show you also what these two
distances mean and what this means you
see all these two numbers mean is the
following I'll pull this down just far
enough to see it
that these two numbers were the widths
from this endpoint to 3 on the one
extreme and from this endpoint to 3 on
the other extreme in other words those
two numbers that we took the minimum of
were the half with intervals that
surrounded 3 you see the problem as we
mentioned before is is that even though
epsilon and my
this epsilon are symmetric with respect
to L when you translate over to the
curve because this curve is not a
straight line when you project down
these two widths will not be equal and
by picking the minimum of these two
widths by picking the minimum of these
two widths you guarantee that you have
locked yourself inside the required area
you see that's all this particular thing
means now the trouble is that one might
now get the idea
that there are no shorter ways of doing
the same problem you see I showed you a
rigorous way there was no law that said
we had to find the biggest Delta in
other words if Delta equals a half will
work in other words if you're within a
half of three something's going to
happen then certainly any smaller number
will work just as well right in other
words I can get estimates let me show
you what I mean by that see another way
of tackling how to make x squared minus
two X minus three smaller than epsilon
is to use our properties of absolute
values and to factor this in other words
we know that x squared minus two X minus
three is X minus three times X plus one
we know that the absolute value of a
product is the product of the absolute
values so these two things here are
synonyms then we know that near x equals
three near x equals three which we're
interested in here x plus one is near
four well what we mean more rigorously
is this choose an epsilon and if the
absolute value of x minus three is less
than epsilon in other words if X minus
three is less than Epsilon but greater
than minus epsilon then by adding on
four to all three sides of the
inequality here we see that X plus one
is less than four plus Epsilon but
greater than four minus Epsilon now you
see if we simply assume that epsilon is
less than 1 in magnitude say if epsilon
and absolute value if the size of
epsilon is less than 1 then certainly
this is less than 5 and this is greater
than 3 now of course somebody may say to
us but what if epsilon is more than 1
well obviously if a guy says make
thing within 10 and I can make it within
one certainly within 10 is within one I
can always pick this smaller number I
missed like that nonsense of the fellow
asking for an ice-cream cone in the
waitress said what flavor and he said
anything except chocolate and she said
I'm all out of chocolate we take
anything except vanilla I mean the idea
is that if somebody says make this less
than 15 if you've made it less than 10
in particular you've made it less than
15 and so all we do over here you see is
something like this we say look at if we
want to make this number here very small
we know that this number here is less
than 5 we know that epsilon over 5 is a
positive number if epsilon is small so
why don't we just pick the absolute
value of X minus 3 to be less than
epsilon over 5 in fact that's what this
Delta will be in that case in other
words if the absolute value of X minus 3
is within epsilon over 5 of 3 see if the
if X is with an epsilon over 5 of 3
notice what this product becomes this is
less than epsilon over 5 this we know
from before is less than 5 and therefore
this product is less than Epsilon in
other words we have exhibited the Delta
such that when this happens the absolute
value of what we want to make less than
Epsilon indeed becomes less than Epsilon
now because I recognize that this is a
hard topic you will notice in the
reading assignments that these problems
are covered in great detail everything
that I've said in the lesson so far is
repeated in great computational depth in
our learning exercises the point is that
even if I can make the Epsilon's and
Delta's seem a little bit more
meaningful for you than by the formal
definition notice that it's simple only
in comparison to what we had before that
it's still very very difficult
the beauty of calculus is that in many
cases we do not have to know what Delta
looks like for a given epsilon what we
shall do therefore in our next lecture
is to develop
recipes that will allow us to get the
answers to these limit problems without
having to go through this genuinely
difficult problem of finding a given
Delta to match a given epsilon though we
must admit in real life in many cases
where you're making approximations we
will want to know what the tolerance
limits are I am NOT belittling the
epsilon Delta approach all I'm saying is
that in certain problems you do not need
the epsilon Delta approach to get nice
results and that will be the topic of
our next lecture so until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate